[Musique]
Bonjour
je suis venu vous parler du conflit
ou plutôt je suis venu vous apporter du
conflit
je vous parle pour qu'il y ait plus de
conflit dans vos vies
plus de conflits dans vos familles
plus de conflit avec vos amis et plus de
conflits bien sûr
à votre travail avec vos collègues pour
chef
et pourquoi est-ce que j'ai un projet
aussi bizarre
je veux plus de conflits dans le monde
pour qu'il y ait moins de violence
alors laissez-moi vous dire d'abord que
je j'ai grandi dans une famille où il y
avait très peu de conflit
une famille où c'était l'époque je suis
plus tout à fait à Millenium
une certaine éducation assez stricte
était de mise et dans cette éducation et
les enfants n'avaient pas le droit de
parler à table
il n'avait pas le droit de réclamer quoi
que ce soit pour le même
répondez pas à leurs parents
pas compris
en plus de ça j'avais un père colérique
colérique
il avait des colères qu'on peut appeler
Amérique
j'étais rarement dirigée contre moi mais
ça me terrifiait
quand ça se passait j'avais envie de
voir de me cacher de disparaître devenir
invisible
si j'étais dans la pièce je ne bougeait
plus sinon j'allais me
me terrer dans ma chambre
soyons franc je n'ai pas été
spécialement maltraité en tout cas selon
les standards de l'époque mais
ça m'a fait violence
pas compris
mets de la violence
et c'est ça qui m'a amené à m'intéresser
au sujet
accompagner des gens dans le conflit et
à vous parler aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui
j'ai trois choses à vous dire et 3
choses que j'aimerais que vous retenir
la première c'est que le conflit
ce n'est pas de la violence
la seconde c'est que il n'y a pas de vie
sans conflit
et la troisième c'est que le conflit
parfois
c'est de la joie
alors le conflit n'est pas la violence
si vous ouvrez le dictionnaire vous
verrez que conflit ça a deux sens
d'abord une lutte armée entre des états
laissons ça de côté
et le deuxième chance et opposition des
accords
différent c'est à ça qu'on va
t'intéresser
je vous propose une nouvelle définition
et cette nouvelle définition c'est le
conflit c'est un désaccord qui nécessite
un ajustement
un désaccord qui nécessite un arrêt
juste
je vous donne un exemple avec mon épouse
un après-midi elle doit aller se
promener moi je veux rester à la maison
chacun peut aller de son côté mais
si nous voulons passer l'après-midi
ensemble alors
il va falloir qu'on sa juste fait un
conflit
un tout petit conflit
mais accompli tout de même
mais c'est moi aussi utiliser une
métaphore j'ai un ami Jean-Philippe qui
est géophysicien à quel TEC l'université
de Californie il étudie les tremblements
de terre il était de passage à Paris il
y a quelques années et on était avec
quelques amis l'écouter nous parler
c'est rechercher de
et bien des endroits dans le monde où il
Kranjec des tremblement de terre sur
Vienne à plus ou moins brève échéance je
me souviens plus des pays qui la cité
mais je me souviens qu'il n'y avait pas
la Californie
et on lui a dit et la Californie alors
la faille de San Andreas cetera
pardon tu nous as dit
on n'est pas inquiet
commence à Paris qui aimait les c'est
une catastrophe les articles Big One
voilà le la réplique du grand
tremblement de terre de San Francisco
ces derniers non non vous a-t-il des on
n'est pas inquiet parce que à Los
Angeles les 30 dernières années il y a
eu plein de tremblement de terre plein
de tremblement de terre
il faut quand vous avez réfléchi c'est
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un tremblement de
terre c'est des plaques les plaques
tectoniques qui sont comme les écailles
de la terre qui bouge indépendamment et
de temps en temps il y en a une qui veut
aller à droite l'autre à gauche et ça
coince
et de la tension s'accumulent dans le
sous-sol s'accumulent s'accumuler un
beau matin pouf une plaque passe
au-dessus l'autre ou l'inverse
et les immeubles qui sont à la surface
tombe
sauf sauf si
cet ajustement se fait par petites
touches au fil des jours c'est les
semaines
c'est ce qui s'est passé
il y a eu plein de tremblement de terre
ces 30 dernières années pas le temps que
je les
et au fond le conflit c'est la même
chose
notre sous-sol
ce sont nos tripes
l'énergie qui s'accumule ce sont les
frustrations leurs sentiments
si nous urgences et énergique nous avons
en haut régulièrement alors notre vie et
notre relation reste debout comme les
immeubles
mais si nous évitons le conflit
alors un bonjour la violence fait
irruption
et détruit notre vie
elle aura la Sion
éviter le conflit c'est acheter de la
tranquillité aujourd'hui
contre de la catastrophe demain
poser le conflit assumé le conflit
c'est s'assurer pour les jours qui
viennent pour les années qui viennent
une vie paisible
le conflit ça n'est pas la violence
c'est maintenant l'heure
deuxième message que j'aimerais vous
transmettre en tout cas partager avec
vous c'est qu'il n'y a pas de vie sans
sans compris je vais
encore vous raconter une histoire une
toute petite histoire fait de toutes
petites choses du quotidien
je sors de chez moi
je vais prendre le métro j'habite à
Paris et sur le chemin je rencontre des
amis que j'ai pas vu depuis longtemps
je suis content de les voir je
m'approche d'eux je vais à leur
rencontre
et en m'approchant je m'aperçois que ils
ont l'air occupé même très occupé
les horaires de discuter sérieusement
peut-être même qui se disputent
je ne vais pas aller déranger
je l'ai laissé
je suis là
par la puissance
j'ai un désir
et j'y renonce
tu peux m'approcher aller les voir
comment ça va je suis content et
blablabla blablabla je leur tape dans le
dos mais peut-être qu'il était en train
de se disputer j'arrive au mauvais
moment j'arrive un peu comme un chien
dans un jeu de qui qui
vont qui vont me racheter tu vois bien
que ce n'est pas le moment
non je suis dans la
taux de puissance
j'ai un désir
et je la sous vie sans prendre en
considération
la situation de mes amis
et entre ces deux extrêmes
la puissance
et la toute-puissance
il y a un point commun
et ce point commun c'est que je fais
tout seul je décide tout seul de ne pas
y aller ou je décide tout seul que non
non il y a pas de problème j'y vais
et surtout seul
c'est le symptôme
de la violence
vous savez la violence et le fait de
s'ouvrir un désir ou
ou de satisfaire un besoin
par force
et dans ces conditions l'autre disparaît
exemple presque ultime
là on est pas dans les toutes petites
choses le grand exemple c'est le viol
l'autre disparaît derrière le désir de
celui qui fait violence
et là mon histoire c'est la même chose
bien sûr à une autre échelle en tout
petit je pense à toi je me fais violence
à moi-même
et dans l'autre je fais violence
même si tu es modeste sur autrui
alors il existe heureusement un chemin
intermédiaire un chemin entre ces deux
comme une crête entre ces deux violence
quitte un chemin de puissance
c'est très simple
Salut je vous dérange vous êtes occupé
je sais pas ce qu'il va arriver
peut-être qu'il va me dire oui non viens
c'est pas le moment qu'un porte
je les aurai déranger un petit peu mais
là
je commence à fabriquer du nous
je commence à fabriquer du ensemble
je vais chercher du consentement ce qui
est tout le contraire de la violence
on se voir dans cette petite histoire
que violence et conflits sont des choses
qui qui viennent dans la moindre des
situations de la vie
la violence et le conflit sont
potentiellement
partout dans nos vies et quoi que vous
fassiez
quelques désire que vous ayez quelques
besoin que vous ayez à satisfaire
dès que vous faites mouvement comme les
plaques tectoniques faux mouvement sur
le monde
alors vous vous exposez
au besoin d'autrui
vous exposer au conflit
et vous ne pouvez pas vivre ni
entreprendre quoi que ce soit sans
déranger autrui livre c'est déranger le
monde
les déranger le monde c'est s'ouvrir la
potentialité du conflit
deuxième message
il n'y a pas de vie sans conflit
et pour le troisième message sur lequel
je vais terminer qui est
le conflit c'est de la Jouarre
c'est le plus difficile mais ça sera le
plus court
si vous m'avez suivi si vous êtes
d'accord avec moi sur ce que je viens de
dire bien
on serait d'accord aussi pour dire que
éviter le conflit
c'est éviter de confronter nos besoins
à ceux des autres
est-ce que je vis avec quelqu'un que ce
soit professionnellement personnellement
sans jamais dévoiler mes besoins
y aller au conflit pour le pour
découvrir les chiens
alors nous allons avoir
une relation superficielle
si au contraire
j'assume le conflit j'assume de mettre
notre relation au risque de nos besoins
divergent
alors si nous avons le le bonheur de
traverser cette épreuve
nous serons que nous sommes capable
ensemble de traverser les tempêtes
et nous en saurons un peu plus sur ce
que l'autre a dans le cœur
c'est pourquoi le conflit
et un chemin vers l'intimité des hêtres
c'est un chemin
faire la joie de la rencontre véritable
le conflit
c'est de la joie
et c'est pourquoi je vous souhaite à
tous
de merveilleux conflit
merci